hey guys and welcome back to the layah heilpern
show powered by icon plus so i want to give a
really quick um shout out to them actually
because icon plus if you guys didn't know so
they're actually a public representative um for
the icon network they've been doing a lot of pr
and marketing um and a lot of us wouldn't
know who iphone network were without um
icon classes hard work so if you do stake your
ics tokens then definitely vote for icon plus
um i also want to say a quick thank you to my
sponsors block fi so i use them to earn up to
8.6 interest on my uscc if you don't know uscc
is a stable coin which is pegged to the us dollar
um i feel like this is going over people's heads
so this is eight point six percent interest is
pretty insane given interest rates are practically
practically flat i can't get my words out
um and across europe we've seen negative interest
rates so that's eight point six percent and on
bitcoin you get around six percent that's pretty
cool um and just finally before we talk bitcoin
and everything else that's going on um i wanna say
another shout out to coinflip um so they are doing
amazing works um they have over 1 000 atms across
the states bringing bitcoin mass adoption to a lot
of different people so i think that's fantastic
i do have a discount code um you can get 10 off
that off their transaction so i'll leave that
code for you guys somewhere in the comments um
but i want to get started today we have a really
cool guest somebody who's an absolute expert on
everything bitcoin everything crypto so i'm gonna
bring him in it is matty greenspan what's up matty
how's it going leia nice to see you it's
good to see you too how is everything i
love the 20k in the background there we go
yeah i think you're good i can't complain
i'm not gonna ask you is it gonna happen yet
i wanna i wanna delve into you before we talk
in the market yeah i mean you're always super
better anybody following me on twitter knows
knows my opinion about this yeah i know
i know we're gonna go into all of this
but for those that don't know a little
bit about you you were previously at etoro
um so you are obviously an absolute expert in this
market in this space so tell us a little bit about
that and you've now founded quantum economics
i think at the beginning of this year was it
yeah november it's uh a year ago i left etoro
and started quantum economics uh two days later
um i my name is matthew greenspan i am a uh i was
the senior market analyst in etoro now the founder
of quantum economics the co-author of the book the
complete guide to fintech investing in a licensed
money manager in the european union that's that's
me that's you okay so i obviously want to talk
about the market um but before we get there you
know i kind of want to understand why we're here
um you know we often talk about this issue
with traditional finance but i don't feel
like that idea and that real issue is kind
of understood enough um even in this even
in this community you know we're all sort of
like oh inflation there's printing money that but
we don't really sort of go into it so if you
could say the top three issues you think there are
with that there is with the traditional
financial system what would that be
well just three huh well you can give
me all of them don't hold back matty
well i i think that one of the main issues um is
that we we live in in mostly in in democracies
these days um but the people who control the money
actually the central banks they control the supply
of money and they they control interest rates
are actually not democratically elected um and
then they're able to make unilateral decisions
that affect everyone um sometimes this can be
a good thing and sometimes not so great of course
i mean there is something to be said for you know
um dictatorship i think that dictatorships often
run smoother than democracies in in many cases
um and you know and if there's an emergency we
can see that it functions certainly better than
uh traditional government and in case in
point right now where we're seeing that
the fed is able to act however they like however
they feel is needed however they feel they feel
the economy uh requires but congress is not right
and that's actually what what needs to happen at
the moment is uh is stimulus from congress
there's two different types of stimulus that
everybody needs to know about there's monetary
stimulus which is from the central banks basically
the central bank's pumping money into the banking
system and fiscal stimulus actually comes from the
government itself right and at the moment monetary
stimulus is abundant the central banks are able
to pump as much as they like but the fiscal
stimulus is harder because it requires agreement
between the different parties democrats and the
republicans they are not getting along right now
whatsoever and therefore they're not able to
provide that fiscal stimulus those stimulus
checks that we saw one thousand two hundred
dollars i think it was back in april everybody
was expecting it to happen again but because
congress can't get together the republicans and
the democrats are deadlocked uh and therefore it's
not happening and the fed just over the last two
days we saw both jerome powell and steven mnuchin
who's the treasury secretary in the white house
um begging congress like practically they could
be like getting down on their knees they might as
well be getting down on their knees right now
please congress just write a check just write
a check and all congress needs to do is say okay
here's the check here's the amount it's not like
a big fundamental flaw i mean there isn't like
everybody agrees it needs to be done but nobody
wants to be seen as the one who's buckling to the
other side um and everybody's trying to get their
little tiny um it's really an issue of pride more
than anything like everybody knows stimulus checks
need to happen you can't take away people's jobs
tell them you're not allowed to work it's illegal
for you to go to work and then not provide
them something to be able to pay the bills
and feed their families at the end of the day
so what's happening i think um is a sham and um
yeah i i i think that that's fine people they
need to wear a mask in public okay fine i don't
i think it's a bit of overkill but if if you
want to go for it right and then tell people um
you know okay so uh you need to have up to five
people in in a in a hundred square meter store or
50 square meter store whatever is the mandate fine
people can wait outside in the line i don't care
but telling people that they're from a certain
industry and therefore they can't work and not not
providing any type of stimulus i mean it's really
i mean we're we're we're we've taken something
that could have been rather trivial and making it
into something that's a multi-generational issue
what is it you mean covert or you mean this
stimulus are you talking the monetary system
which bit right well all of it together i suppose
i mean covet you know it is it is a problem
and i do know people who've contracted
covet and people who've died from it and
and it sucks but um at the end of the
day uh the damage that's being done
to the economy right now is f is far
outweighing that and i believe that um
the government is in a position that they can
rectify it somewhat but they're refusing to and
over silly reasons yeah i mean i i mean it kind of
just shocks me i feel like there's so many things
that we're not allowed to talk about and we're
sort of not allowed to talk about the fact that
you know there's that 99.9 survival rate and if
you're those are those your kids in the background
very cute um yes sorry no worries it's okay and
you know if you're over i think over 70 it's
around 94 survival rate so i would definitely say
there's a huge overreach um i mean if you're going
to stop people from working then of course
you're going to have to sort of that's your
responsibility you have to sort of make up for
that financially um but you know i just say just
let people work you know i think it's pretty
interesting the way um you know a lot of the
time in life and in society we have the freedom to
decide how much risk that we want to take but it's
kind of odd in this situation we're not allowed
to decide how much risk we want to take you know
smoking kills you but we are within our right
to take that risk you know you can die getting
on a getting on a plane you can die by driving um
you know but we're within our rights to take that
risk um you know as a woman i could get attacked
by getting it you know walking alone at night um
but it's not illegal to do that um i just know you
know i can weigh up my risk i can say okay well
you know i'm small i'm very small actually in real
life um you know i'm i where you can take karate i
mean yeah you know and you defend yourself that's
your decision to make exactly but given i know
that i'm at risk i wouldn't walk through a dark
park on my own at night so we have that freedom
to decide you know how much risk we want to take
it kind of surprised i don't know if it surprises
me i just don't know why we're not following
through um you know when it comes to this
yeah it is a bit bamboozling and and but
to to to your question i mean what are the
the the flaws within the financial system i
mean this is an apparent a blatant one where
you know congress is not able
to provide are your little ones
yes
guys while matty speaks to his little ones um i
just want to also let you know we're doing more
intense negotiations here you're an intense
negotiation that's fine i'll i'll i'll i'll
chat to my i'll chat to my audience so i just
want to thank you guys all so much for tuning in
um i can see that we have um we have matthew
that's tuned in thank you so much we've got
blockchain monkeys who says this is a great show
so thank you so much nebula is here jason williams
is here who now identifies apparently um as a big
chocolate man that's what jason williamson yeah
he's now identified as a big chocolate man
which which is which is interesting because he's
quite the opposite are you eating are you still
in intense negotiations what do we have you matty
yes um we have you we're i'm back you're
back cool okay right i want to talk about
the financial system i want to know the problem
um you said you know it's undemocratic which
is pretty interesting you know they get to make
these decisions like printing x amount of money
we never voted um to allow that to happen
um but other than on it being undemocratic
tell me more of the problems something so
simple that i can turn around to my friends
and say these are the problems this is why you
need to be encrypted this is why you need bitcoin
sure so the sim the simple fact of the matter is
that fiat currency or currency that is unbacked
and created uh unilaterally by governments is
designed intentionally to depreciate over time
um you see the the central bankers talking about
uh inflation as if uh the lack of inflation is is
a criminal thing or a very bad thing that needs
to be rectified right they say okay we're not you
know um we need to get to two percent inflation
we need to we need to have more inflation we
need to have more inflation meaning what what
they what they're saying is i mean very clearly
is that we need to devalue the money that's in
your bank account right it sounds absurd but why
but that's what's happening um there are many
reasons for it and then there could be you know
uh there are cases to be made why inflation can
be a good thing for economy for an economy um
for the most part it pushes people towards
consumerism right if you know that the money
in your bank account is going to be worth less
in five years you're less likely to save it and
more likely to spend it i find that so sickening
like that's so sickening like there's nothing um
that's kind of like um it's not like it's not a
positive thing it's kind of holding you hostage
isn't it it's kind of blackmailing you yeah it's
incredible it's it's slavery to consumerism it's
what's been happening for last several decades
at least yeah i mean it just blows my mind you
know because people celebrate quantitative easing
and they sort of say yeah you know it stimulates
the economy it gets people to spend but but it's
absolute blackmail in my opinion there's nothing
positive it's like hang on i don't want to spend
you know we spend too much black friday is stupid
we spend way too much you know we don't need all
of these things and i was watching a documentary
recently about minimalism not that i'm into
minimalism that much to be honest but you know
i mean there's something to be said about
having too much stuff and people sort of buying
um to find happiness in these things but it's
really empty i want to talk about inflation
though because our inflation rates that we see
in the west you're obviously in the middle east
um you know it's not what we see in countries like
venezuela for example right um and so when i often
put forward this argument about inflation people
are just like no you know this is normal this is
natural inflation rates whatever that means
so we don't see hyperinflation so despite not
seeing any hyperinflation here would you still
see say you know inflation is actually an issue
that is a good question and um because covet
19 is completely uh screwed with all of the
barometers that we have to understand the economy
um we have to understand what's happening here so
first of all within the first two months of
the covet 19 lockdowns uh more money had been
injected into the american economy than had been
in the first 200 years of america's existence um
now a logical person would say okay more
money supply therefore you know supply and
demand therefore the demand on the currency goes
down and the value of the currency goes down um
but economists are very quickly finding that this
isn't always the case and over the last 10 years
um we've seen them testing pushing the limits
more further and further how much can we print um
and not have inflation and what they're really
seem to be scared about is deflation right where
the god forbid the people the money in people's
bank accounts should actually increase in value
over time um why don't they why would they be
scared about it it's bad for it's bad for business
people people end up saving rather than spending
okay so it's the opposite what we were just saying
okay i'm with you exactly um so generally so
generally speaking i mean inflation isn't isn't
all all that like a bad thing but the problem
is when um they continued to they continued to
push this money in and because because of covet
19 now we see um all of a sudden people aren't
spending anyways right so because people aren't
spending um they're we don't see any kind of
movement in the economy and therefore inflation
cannot happen inflation can only really happen
once we see the velocity pick up where money
is actually changing hands on a regular basis
uh that's when inflation occurs so right
now what we're seeing is it's basically
um imagine like uh a punch uh a punch uh jug of
punch or whatever right you have the powder and
you mix in all the powder and um so they've been
stirring right and then they put the they put the
powder in and they you know they see the powder
just keeps dripping down to the bottom right
and then now we have a situation where and rather
than rather than stirring it up and making the
powder move around the jug they just keep pouring
more powder in right and now you have a jug that's
like half powder and half this uh kind of a mush
but you know that once people go back to work
right eventually we hope that you know these lock
downs will be over and people are going to go out
and spend again they're going to go travel and
they're going to go on vacation and they're going
to go uh and get back to their to normal lives
that's when things get stirred up and this is
bad and that's when things can potentially get
very nasty because we have all of that excess
powder in the bottom once things get stirred
around it's going to be really uh okay i don't
know yeah interesting so just to like clarify that
so for inflation to sort of happen and take place
the money needs to be spent so right now we're not
going to see the effects because everything's shut
down we're not spending but then once everything
starts going back into circulation that makes
sense that makes perfect sense once everything go
back into circulation that's when we're going to
see it essentially yeah uh very likely this is
what economists are expecting but uh the more
the more we learn the more we realize that our
previous assumptions are are simply moot and and
unreliable okay so speaking of deflationary assets
let's talk about bitcoin um you're new on the
overall markets right now so i want to talk about
your view on bitcoin firstly do you think that
it's performed well this year um i'm obviously
going to get on to what's happening right now you
know at the beginning of the ball round but let's
just talk about 2020 you know i i've been reading
that the dollars down um bitcoin's clearly not
so so what are your thoughts on bitcoin this year
yeah i mean bitcoin has consistently been an
out performer of of everything in the world
yeah i mean we've seen it since it's it's since
its creation basically i mean there have been
very few years when it hasn't outperformed every
other financial asset on the planet yeah and at
the beginning of this year my prediction was the
same it was exactly they asked me for a comment on
and i said that this is look this is how it's
done there's little reason to suspect that it
won't do that again um and therefore you
know obviously the bulk of my investments
uh right now at this moment in time are in
bitcoin um with of course uh fail states involved
because you know sometimes we get both 20 30
corrections what kind of fell safe is of interest
um well we've got these big monitors up
make sure that uh we don't uh we don't
cross any of those red lines if we do then we
uh cut exposure a little bit what red light
what would be red light for you um like a 10k line
or yes i would say 10k i don't think that look
i think that there's a real possibility that
we'll never see uh bitcoin below 10 000 ever again
um but if you want to pull up the chart we've
got a few lines of support coming up here
pull that up let's have a look can we see it
okay so we're getting live uh we're getting a live
ta here this is fab all right 10k right there's
there is that is an ultimate level of support
as far as i see uh 12k 14k and then 16k but i
think 16th favorite could probably move it to 16
and a half i think it's more relevant and a half
um but the fun thing here is that every
single these were these lines had never
existed previously right because
the first time we went from 10k
come back come back they said the first time
that we went from 10k to 20k we went up so
fast to two weeks and we came back down so fast
that the charts didn't have enough time to build
up proper support and resistance lines but now
we've seen that they did and we can see that the
way that they interacted with these levels so 10k
if you'll recall um it took a while for it to test
this right i mean look at look at it testing here
testing here testing here testing here once it did
that once it did break through it blasted through
and it didn't just go through it and went all the
way up to 12k before uh before even slowing
down and stopping and we can see 12k the same
same thing it tested here retraced critical
that it pulled back and tested that 10k as
a support level right and then we can see once it
got back to that 12k it blasted through right now
and then got all the way up to 14k before pulling
back ever so slightly we didn't ever get a test
of 12k level which i would have liked to see but
didn't come a bit closer again come a bit closer
again yeah i said we kind of i wish we would have
tested that 12k again as a support but we didn't
okay and then 16 and a half we blasted through 16
and a half we have now tested as a support level
right now things can count if things do get
ugly they turn around right now and it would
be a shame certainly to to come all this way and
not see that level of 10 of 20k um but you know
these are markets and things happen uh so then we
have all of these levels as valid support levels
on the way down meaning that we can take a 16
and a half now we can take 14 and we can take
12 and we can see those um as excellent
opportunities to add to your position i believe
in my opinion anyways um now the question is what
happens at 20k right do we do we behave the same
way as we did with 10k test it for a while test it
again test it again and then blast right through
if that happens i mean the sky is the limit right
i don't see i don't see there's after that there
are no you know just as we were before uh once
we're in all-time high territory there are no
marks of resistance so we can go 100k
a million 2 million 5 million who knows
like the millions yes because of digital scarcity
and people people miss this and you know i'm you
know certainly you know there have been people
who've picked higher numbers than me i'm sure and
i i'm very hesitant to make any kind of final
call um certainly at 80k i'll be ready to take
some profits right yes um but what people don't
understand is that the charts don't always matter
right this is um you know as a licensed portfolio
manager every time we talk about the charts uh the
regulator says you need to add the disclaimer past
performance does not indicate future results okay
and it's very true when you're looking at
charts what you're seeing is past performance
and we can't make any type of uh forward-looking
statements based on based on history we can only
say that history has a tendency to repeat itself
and those price levels are now relevant we can't
necessarily say what will happen once the relevant
price levels are reached um so be that as it may
the charts are not necessarily what's important
here what's important here are the fundamentals
or actually how many bitcoin are available
are available on the market for purchase
right and what we saw in 2017 was there was none
like we had times when people were trying to buy
and they could not at any price get them right
and when you're in a situation where you cannot
get them at any price and people still want still
have the desire to purchase then the price goes up
very very quickly right because the buyer is then
forced to raise his buying price until he gets
uh somebody who goes okay you know
what for that price i'll sell it to you
right um and this is why again we we can analyze
the charts all we want um and many will but at the
end of the day what what's really at play here
is this uh ingenious design by satoshi nakamoto
um uh with of implementing a hard cap at 21
million uh and then that's it there isn't any more
yeah my gosh i mean it's so insane when we you
know when you pull out those numbers and we're
also you know i'm also in a world where people
can't even understand why bitcoin matters and
you know even saying that bitcoin has a use
case whether that's as a store of value or
whatever it is people are often just like you
know it's a ponzi scheme it's a pump and dump
it's this and that um so yeah it's super insane
to hear that um okay so so you know you mentioned
numbers like let's just say one million okay
let's just play with this number for a second
if it was to reach something like that even
on its way up to something like that what
does bitcoin really need to be right like does it
need to be a payments system does it need to be
um just as a store of value um does it you
know does it have to just be digital gold
obviously you know we know it doesn't work
fantastically well as a payment system just
given you know it takes so long it's expensive
are you kidding me no tell me tell me go on okay
out of the 14 members of quantum economics
uh 10 of them would prefer to receive a payment in
bitcoin yeah me and myself 100 it's not only that
i i find it constantly like a constant struggle
i'll tell my bank and i have i i have a very good
bank and they give me a very great service is that
an israeli out of interest no morgan stanley they
get they they give me a very good service where
i have a dedicated account manager and i tell
them okay i want to transfer here is the digits
here's the num here's the bank account that i
want to transfer to and then come back to me we
couldn't find it or um the payment was returned i
don't know why but i i waited two business days to
figure out that the the payment didn't go through
yeah and and at that point i just go to go okay
give me your btc address he has it in 10 minutes
this happens to me over and over and over again
right so as a means of payment it's already
way ahead of of the the banking system yeah
absolutely agree with you it is way ahead of
the banking system but just in terms of i don't
know other potential cryptocurrencies even if
it's stable coins i don't know whatever it is
or i mean a lot of them just work a lot faster
um i think it's nano that does it in seconds so
you know do you think that bitcoin could become
that global payments i don't know you know replace
the dollar as that global payment um like solution
or do you think you know we're not gonna get that
my opinion on this is less relevant only because
while i'm i'm on the show with you actually just
before that i took a hiatus from writing my daily
quantum economics newsletter um yesterday
we highlighted uh larry fink who is the ceo
of blackrock and blackrock for those of you
don't know is the largest money manager in
the world they have seven uh point something
trillion dollars under management they're the
personal piggy bank also of the federal reserve
their uh kind of liquidity provider for them um
one of the main benefactors of course of
the last 10 years of quantitative easing
and uh larry fink uh and this is what i'm
writing about today because yesterday i
was so excited about the announcement today i
actually went in and analyzed what did he say
and i'll be publishing it in
just a bit but he actually
questioned he he brought the question can bitcoin
or something like it uh replace the us dollar as
the global reserve currency think about it i mean
this is something that you know in 2011 you know
visionaries like you know charlie lee and
vitalik with terry and you know yoni asia and
um you know uh many uh several others i mean not
very many people at that time we're talking about
right we can have tokenized assets that are on
a blockchain and they're superior to traditional
assets in less than 10 years that idea has
now propagated to you okay no what's happened
the highest bank in all of the
land the number one runner of money
of private equity in the entire world is now
talking about this idea of the tokenized future
hello leia's daddy's good friend hello
no hellos okay well we're going to talk
oh of course sorry okay okay that makes sense
okay so yeah i mean absolutely the sentiment
has completely changed um over the last ten
years to even have these kind of um questions um
it's pretty insane so in terms of you know
bitcoin is moving right now i think it's around
19.2 or 19.3 um where do you where do you
expect it to go i know we've obviously mentioned
there's been a lot of support but
are you expecting a correction
anytime soon um you know we're sort of testing
new highs um what what do you expect for 2021
yeah i get and again you know um you've got
the 20k in the background there i yeah look
because i i i like this as a round number and
um i believe that it is extremely possible
uh any day now i mean we could we could
reach it but again you know this is um
uh it's it's impossible to tell the
future leia i mean i i'm i wouldn't be
i wouldn't i mean i wouldn't be a very
good asset manager if i tried to do that
no good and i respect that i can't stand you know
when we're always hearing like it's gonna like you
know we're gonna reach this price on this day i
mean we just don't know i think overall you know
there's a bullish sentiment you know we we believe
in the asset we understand um the fundamentals
behind it and i guess that's kind of all you can
do um but you know in terms of being this global
currency it would need to scale right um so do
you think bitcoin can scale i know there's the
lightning network but that's kind of not very
user-friendly what are your thoughts on this
right so yeah the lightning network i think is
a failed experiment there's taken them a very
long time uh to come to that uh realization
but i think even the people who are behind
it by now are starting to understand that it's not
it's not moving very fast or it's it's come to a
kind of a roadblock i think that even uh according
to the latest uh the latest uh reports that i
saw um there's more bitcoin on on the ethereum
network than there is in the lightning network
um i do believe very uh very strongly in the
power of uh stable coins um i think that and
especially with uh the excellent work from brian
brooks uh where he's basically um legitimized uh
the entire industry of stable coins so basically
we're going to see kind of a digitization of the
us dollar not as a central bank digital currency
but as the way that uh currencies are today
um you know the commercial banks are the ones
that print dollars they're the ones who create
the dollars right based on the reserves of the
central bank they can lend out uh multiple times
on every single dollar so for every dollar in the
federal reserve they can then lend out uh 10 times
now infinity times because there isn't any kind of
um uh fractional or minimum fractional requirement
um so at the end of the day but but the
inherent problem with that is that um
you know you get you get to a point where uh
there's contagion in the system right meaning
that uh the the dollars printed at uh jpmorgan
are equal exactly to the dollars printed at
wells fargo and jp morgan is obviously a much more
sound and stable financial institution whereas you
know wells fargo has their issues right um so when
we get to the point where jpmorgan is able to to
print jpmorgan dollars and wells fargo is able
to print wells fargo dollars then we can see that
there's um you know the the market can react to
those differently and then if something happens
to wells fargo something happens to their
dollars and not to the u.s dollar which is
which can bring top-fold the entire system i think
that's extremely healthy for the system and um in
many ways even greater than what china's working
on with their central bank digital currency is to
let the corporate world lead um as they always
do uh within the us economy and they think that
that's that's true capitalism and i think that
that's what's going to end up prevailing at the
end of the day yeah so this this kind of brings
you into a really interesting point actually um
about cbdc's um and versus cryptocurrencies
right because they're obviously not exactly
the same thing um so as we move forward right
and we move towards this lot of digital money
we're already hearing like you said you know
china and there's cbdc so in my opinion i feel
like there's going to be this tug of war between
the two um you know you know you're talking about
bitcoin potentially as this global currency so do
you think we're going to see a tug of war do you
think they could actually work simultaneously
um the same way cash and you know right now
so i guess digital money sort of works
simultaneously albeit they are on the
same side they're the same thing um you know
do you think we're gonna see like a tug of
war between the two like the government and the
freedom movement or how do you see it playing out
i'm not really sure how what you're what you're
asking okay so we're moving forward right
with cryptocurrencies and we're talking about
cryptocurrencies potentially being um this global
currency that everybody's using you know you're
obviously a fan of stable coins that you said um
you're paying people in bitcoin but meanwhile
governments are creating their own cbdc's
so in my opinion digital money is inevitable
everything's going digital you know the way
we socialize is digital the way we work is digital
dating is digital eating is digital you know
everything is digital so it only makes sense
that money will become digital but will it be
the government's version of crypto right like
the cbdc's or will it be our version of crypto
do you think they can work side by side or do you
think there'll be a tug of war between the two
in terms of being that global currency that
everybody uses right so i think that there
is um it's going to be very interesting how it
how it will play out um at this point i see it
kind of as like you know a game of pickup sticks
where you've got the bundle and then you just
drop it i mean to say exactly how it's going
to play out here would be very difficult
and we can kind of hypothesize right in my view um
you know china has come out with their centralized
cbdc um the united states is coming out with a
very decentralized system for digitizing the us
dollar um and i don't i don't know if that's going
to play in in the power dynamics or affect the
us dollars uh ability to perform as the as the
global reserve currency i think that the banks
will be able to innovate fast enough to thwart
off uh the advances of china i think they will be
um what you have in europe on the other hand is
something very different where they're coming out
with it seems well they're still you know back and
forth and of course uh christine lagarde was very
likely put in in her position as the european
uh central bank boss simply because of her her
thoughts on digital currency um there's a there's
a very they have they have a paradox right because
they want to uh upgrade the system and it's
very clear that it's there are benefits of that
but in the other hand um they have uh issues
of privacy right um corporate uh structure in
the united states as we see you know each each
bank will be able to uh protect the privacy of
their customers at different levels right so some
banks will be able to offer privacy as a feature
and might attract customers based on that feature
right similar to the way apple is doing now they
say okay this is the privacy phone the government
can't get your can't get access to it uh so
i believe that there will be banks to say okay
your dollars that you're holding are very private
um in europe it seems like they're trying to come
out with a centralized system um but also try to
maintain privacy and this is going to be extremely
difficult to do from a technical perspective um
in europe and this is where my my financial
license is from europe i've seen it firsthand
their compliance is like especially with
anti-money laundering laws they're so
afraid that terrorists might actually get
money into the system and buy things with it
that they actually just like uh they refuse
a lot of legitimate business based on that
um and i think that they're gonna find it very
difficult to have their cake if needed too
like how can you on the one hand crack down on on
money laundering and tax evasion and all of those
things that you're afraid of and on the same at
the same time protect the privacy of your citizens
the working paper that i read which came out a few
months ago uh was that they're going to say okay
um for large you know for small transactions
and each person will be entitled to a certain
amount of privacy credits where you can make
small transactions that are fly underneath the
radar and are completely private and nobody will
understand but for larger purchases uh they'll be
reported by you know to the government so that's
almost like saying okay so um you can have your
bedroom okay you can do whatever you want in
your bedroom but we're gonna have to install a
camera in your living room for your own protection
right so to be this like i it doesn't that's not a
solution i think that they're gonna they're gonna
find this paradox extremely difficult to solve
yeah no i'm taking with you and i i think you know
seeing how those different sort of i guess power
side power plays play out i think will be really
will be really interesting but just on a final
note then regulation is something i just quickly
wanted to go over with you um it's something that
we're talking a lot about at the moment um paypal
um their ceo are calling for the community to
um to work hand in hand with regulators which i
think is quite funny um so what are your thoughts
you know is regulation the good old necessary evil
um can you even regulate bitcoin or is it going to
be you know regulating the on our end you know
um in terms of i don't know making it making it
you know kind of trying to think of something
my head we could do you know make it clear how
much you hold and who you're transacting with
and and having to fill out papers and this and
i don't know i mean can you regulate it right and
this just kind of goes along the lines of what uh
you know what ray dalio was asking about which
i i covered in the uh newsletter uh last week
right because he he asked some very good
questions about bitcoin so why can't you know
if it gets too big why wouldn't the government
ban it um the simple answer is they can't um
because you know it's a peer-to-peer uh system
and uh technically it would be very difficult
even if they would uh pour all of their resources
into it and collaborate with several countries it
would be extremely difficult if they did if that
was the level i think that bitcoin would have
a very big fight right there there would be
challenges um but at the la at present time we
we don't really see that push from governments
and um as far as you know in 2017 we had right
there was during that time there was the fear
and then there was the government's going okay
with the exception of brad sherman i don't
think that anybody in in the united states
government really wants to outlaw bitcoin at
this point right um you know we saw those tweets
from brian armstrong about mnuchin and the the
personal custody wallets and stuff like that
um i think that that was there might have been an
idea floated in passing that brian was responding
to and he's correct to respond to because when
there are bad ideas you you know the industry
needs to rise up and say this is a bad idea
because xyz just as bryan had done i don't think
that he had an intention to crash the the price or
anything like that although you know we never know
um but at the end of the day we can see that the
government is a and and it seems to me even those
laws that he was responding to were proposed uh
in favor of the currency without understanding the
my new details but they actually understood that
okay there is something here that we can uh that
we should be watching and we should do something
about and then they proposed something and this is
just about that that's just a bad idea leave it
alone and now that now that that has happened
they of course they left it alone if the community
on the other hand if the community would have said
hey that's a great idea right uh maybe there
would have been a different reaction to those
proposals and uh something could have gone
through and again in a deadlock congress right
now and nothing's going to go through so it's
really a moot point but it's still important
to debate the ins and outs yeah i just think
it's interesting because that was that whole
conversation as well with um raul powell and you
know he was sort of saying regulation will happen
and you know you will still use bitcoin um you
know do you think it's such an inevitable thing
though in the way that he does or are you just
sort of very much on the lines of you know the
community were rejected like you just said
and it's also physically not quite possible
yeah i mean the thing about cryptocurrencies
and it's giving regulators a real run for their
money because um regulators are used to dealing
local first and then expanding right so you have
a market in that's in new york for example right
which is you know maybe a few hundred years ago
just starting out and you had to keep an eye on
it and then as it glow grows it becomes you know
it becomes more of an international thing
but the market physically still resides in
new york city you can go visit it right um
with cryptocurrencies uh you have a market
which is suddenly brand new it's global first it
doesn't have a physical address um and therefore
uh regulators they don't they don't really know
how to tackle it and what what we're finding
though and again there's you know always this tug
of war that it has actually given somewhat of a
mandate for regulators that are global in nature
which didn't really have a place until now are now
finding it uh finding newfound power a newfound
mandate to step in and say okay now we have this
problem so now the government in this area the
global government should get together so in a way
i mean we have for example united nations i have
always this since being a child have advocated for
um you know a global government right one that
kind of operates you know and i think that that
could uh certainly do wonders as far as you know
reducing war and poverty um but and and maybe in
this way uh bitcoin heals the world you know what
i'm saying like it pushes the global governments
gives them more power um and then they can then
come and and and i don't know join forces but
again the nice way to end right the pickup sticks
and see how they land yeah it's a nice way to end
it could heal the world i mean i guess you
know talk about global government it depends
you know in what sense and in what way um but
anyway matty it's been such a pleasure thank you
so much for joining me um where can people find
you what are your last words just promote yourself
yes certainly uh twitter of course and uh come
to quantum economics dot io sign up for the
newsletter uh it's gold there you go thanks so
much everyone follow matty if you're not already
and everyone thank you so much for tuning in
i will see you next thursday 12 p.m est bye